my name is Costas donor I'm a senior
fellow at Stanford Freeman spogli
Institute for International Study of a
ragtag group that is a mixed group with
some of the leadership clearly coming
from Moscow that is mr. bird I is a sin
salir of the separatists and the dynamic
People's Republic he's coming from
Lawndale keeping him a self-proclaimed
leader that look a little bit serious
the defense minister is unknown Russian
military intelligence agent and his name
is igor strelkov sort of his num de
guerre and she dressing things on the
ground what a separatist his real name
is igor jerkin the guys who've been
walking access to the point clearly
local from the area not particularly
sophisticated mobley unemployed or
underemployed for a long time and have
had cause to be angry with the previous
Ukrainian government Ukrainian economy
was in a very bad situation still is so
their concerns are real they don't
really make anything there isn't a high
degree of assessment been a lot of
stability I think we can call it a civil
war now yes for sure and it's civil war
that being supported by an outside power
and that's Russian
you